alors à son propos on a beaucoup parlé
de la françafrique ce système présumé
clientéliste d' échange de bons procédés
de quoi s'agit-il qui en a bénéficié
pourquoi et comment ce système perdure
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé jérôme berlin frédéric de la rue
entré dans le bureau d'omar bongo
c'était ouvrir un livre d'histoire sur
les murs tout la vème république et un
air de françafrique feu doux jusqu'à
depuis sur son mur il avait trouvé de la
place pour nicolas sarkozy
omar bongo avait une passion immodérée
pour la politique française au point dit
certain de la finance est un ex
président accuse à son tour valéry
giscard d'estaing
selon lui omar bongo a contribué à la
campagne de jacques chirac en 80 plus
bongo et je lui ai dit vous soutenez
financièrement la campagne de mon
concurrent alors y ait eu un temps mort
que j'entends encore et ma vie or vous
le savez ce qui était merveilleux
médiocre polémique rétorque jacques
chirac et ses proches de l'époque je ne
les ai jamais vus distribuer de l'argent
en tous les cas en ce qui me concerne ce
n'était pas mon cas je dirais simplement
que sur giscard d'estaing compte tenu
des fonctions qu'il a occupées ne peut
pas dire n'importe quoi sans en apporter
les preuves
preuve ou non la vieille querelle entre
deux vieux ennemis relance une vieille
affaire la françafrique ou comment
conforter des régimes dans les anciennes
colonies
pour mieux servir les intérêts de la
france longtemps la françafrique eu un
visage celui de jacques foccart
résistant gaulliste
le monsieur afrique du général c'est lui
qui intronise omar bongo un ancien des
services secrets français
c'est lui qui fait du gabon le pivot de
ces réseaux reconnaît que les relations
je me suis créé avec des commerçants
européens et par la suite mais les les
chefs d'état africains constituent un
réseau mais je n'appelle pas ça réseau
ces réseaux vont perdurer d'année en
année à droite comme à gauche
considèrent que les deux septennats de
françois mitterrand n'ont pas été
parfaitement clair sur le plan de la
françafrique
je considère qu omar bongo et d'autres
chefs d'état africains ont beaucoup fait
des beaucoup de dirigeants français et
je crains que ses dirigeants n'est pas
toujours forcément été à droite et
aujourd'hui où en est on selon les
experts la france n'aurait plus ni les
moyens ni l'envié de jouer au feutre de
roi parce que ici à paris il ya une
normalisation une des relations
franco-africaines banalisation et le
président nicolas sarkozy off n'hésite
pas à dire que la france a plus intérêt
au proche et au moyen-orient en afrique
une page serait donc tourner son
excellence el hadj omar bongo emporte
ses nombreux secrets lui qui n'hésitait
pas à dédicacer ses livres
ainsi la force du silence est majeur en
amitié